So leute der stream titel ist programm heute gibt es only high iq javascript
Was high iq ist entscheide selbstverständlich ich
Der chat kann es auch nicht entscheiden der chat hat nicht genug primes ab dementsprechend fehlt dem chat in der der high iq selbst
Das funktioniert so nicht nur ich kann heute entscheiden was high iq ist
Und eins ist sicher
Keine tests schreiben ist auch high iq verschwendet man keine zeit und wenn man eh perfekte software programmiert dann braucht man auch keine tests ganz einfach
Tests sind richtig massive bloated genauso wie kommentare und sowas braucht auch keiner
Aber ehrlich gesagt kommentare durchaus
Ernsthaft wirklich bloated sein können wenn sie schwachsinnig sind so was weiß ich
So die kommentare die die irgendwelche leute in der berufsschule schreiben so i gleich 0 da schreiben die dann
Setz i to 0 da braucht halt keiner das kommentar da sieht jeder
Test korrekt was da alles kaputt gehen kann das ist genau mit verschlüsselung
Ach ich habe gedacht ich habe gerade gedacht ich hätte das angeschaltet
Weil ich habe gerade aus versehen auf dem zweiten monitor random irgendwas gedrückt und da habe ich schon gedacht ich bin gerade auf diesen button gekommen
Nachdem wir anschließend leute müssen wir erst mal das wichtigste des tages machen
Gleich müssen wir noch eine ordentliche musik playlist anmachen aber wir müssen das wichtigste des tages machen erst mal package updates
erst mal package updates
Moment moment moment sekunde
Das muss jetzt sein
Exzellent bis bis die bis die package updates durch sind
package updates
Sagen
Shortcut geht nicht package updates
Das ist hier was wird geupdated zeigt her was wird geupdated pnpm passend zu unserem javascript stellt es natürlich
heißen demen und cute
cute base basiertes cute sein
Für die webs da gibt es nichts
Das war jetzt aber wenig art by the way
was da am wochenende lief
Okay genug das brauche ich jetzt nicht in endlos schleife
Was das hier wupp wupp wupp in endlos schleife nicht copy url auch gut wupp wupp wupp wupp geht immer im hintergrund
schad 2 schad 2 verschlüsseln ich mache alles rott 26
war doch 26 oder wie das gleiche rauskommt
huge massive questions hier
Also kirwo was gibt es denn hey max gut ich gut erwische ich dich mal im stream ja
Ich bin letzterzeit aber relativ oft on
Aber nicht lang ich meine ich mache keine acht stunden streams wie fulltime streamer weiß gar nicht wie man das aushält
Da muss man doch der hals wehtun weil
Ich habe eine frage bei der du mir vielleicht weiterhelfen kannst ich werde computer und netzwerk studieren wenn das heißt wirklich so computer und netzwerk
Und frage mich im moment wo man danach damit arbeitet gibt es firmen die das internet weiterentwickeln hört sich für mich nach etwas an
Was nur google und co machen weißt du also was die machen in deinem studiengang da computer und netzwerk
Das weiß ich auch nicht aber da gibt es noch sicherlich einen plan
Wenn man sich den plan mal anguckt da kann man wahrscheinlich auch besser einordnen was sie da drunter verstehen
Mein computer und netzwerk das kann ja alles und nichts sein
Das ist eine copypasta glaube ich nicht
Das ist das ist nicht copypasta leicht genug
Aber es ist es ist es ist zumindest genug text dafür dass es copypasta copypasta sein könnte
Computer architecture und security auf allen lernst du halt wie sowas funktioniert das kannst du überall später gebrauchen
Der chat wo sind wir eigentlich stehen geblieben gestern
Aber um das hier mal zu beantworten ja es gibt tatsächlich
Firmen die das internet weiterentwickeln große netzwerk hardware hersteller ausstatter die entwickeln schon in gewisser weise das internet weiter
Das internet entwickelt sich permanent weiter
Und zum beispiel tut sich auch protokollseitig was
Weil erinnert sich noch einer an die an die falsch gepushten bgp routen von irgendeinem bulgarischen provider
Wo bei der telekom das dsl kundennetz nicht mehr richtig funktioniert hat weil die das umgeroutet haben
Das sind so dinger da wird sich in zukunft sicherlich noch einiges tun
Muss man gerade gucken ob sich nach den videos von heute morgen ein youtuber
Youtube hat sich immer noch nicht eingekriegt youtube denkt immer noch ich soll mir jedes
Elric sieht das video angucken was auf dieser welt existiert
Passt auf jetzt kommt ja es geht gleich weiter
Und und mit jedem anklicken
Mit jedem anklicken wird der youtube denkt der youtube algorithmus immer noch noch mehr ich will das gucken
Aber anscheinend will ich das ja auch gucken sonst würde ich ja nicht anklicken
How to code every day mehr zu sehen
Wo du landest hängt auch entscheidend davon ab wo du dich bewirbst und was es bei dir in der nähe so gibt wenn es was kleineres ist
Zumal in tag in zeiten von
Remote möglichkeiten sind ja die
Ja, ich glaube das ist auch ein guter punkt
Ich glaube das ist auch ein guter punkt
Remote möglichkeiten sind ja die
Ja ist ja die auswahl größer
Das hängt von dir ab danach und wenn du das studiert hast wirst du ja auch bescheid wissen
Und wirst dich nicht bewerben mit ich kenne mich mit computer und netzwerk aus
Hot cheesecake
Also ich kann dir sagen
Unabhängig davon
Was du genau studierst
Du wirst auf jeden fall einen job finden
IT technisch ist so mangelware aktuell
Die suchen alle hände ringend nach leuten
Gut ob du dann da hin willst
Die die leute suchen
Das ist natürlich wieder was anderes Jobs gibt es genug
Richtig gute Jobs gibt es aber auch nicht wie Sand am Meer
Also es gibt an jeder ecke einen Job
Ob du den allerdings haben willst und ob du da Bock drauf hast
Ist natürlich wieder was anderes
Deswegen finde ich es immer so witzig
Wenn man irgendwelche 0815 Klitschen der Meinung sind
Sie sind hier irgendwie
Google 2.0
Oder Microsoft
Oder Instagram
Oder was ist Fang nochmal
Facebook
Amazon
Apple
Netflix
Google
Oder
Müsste das nicht eigentlich mittlerweile fahren
Heißen
Weil es ist ja eigentlich nicht mehr Google sondern Alphabet
Weil Google hat sich ja irgendwie
Nein nicht wirklich umbenannt
Sondern sowas obendrüber noch gegründet
Was ja Alphabet heißt
Also die haben natürlich nach wie vor genug
Bewerber
Aber
Ich meine so eine 0815 Klitsche um die ecke ist halt nicht
Google 2.0
Stimmt Facebook ist auch Meta und nicht mehr Facebook
Aber jeder sagt noch Facebook
Ja
Das hört sich doch schon besser an
Da hast du einen
Breiten Überblick danach
Elektrotechnik und Informationstechnik
Fachrichtung
Computer und Netzwerke
Ja vielleicht entwickelst du dann doch mal irgendwann das
Internet neu
Twitter war
Lustigerweise noch nie dabei
Was ist
Okay wir müssen mal kurz eine Sache gucken bevor wir anfangen
Was ist eigentlich aus
Tweemoji
Tweemoji Fork geworden
Gibt es
Okay gab es auf dem offiziellen Tweemoji Updates
Nein Tweemoji Updates gab es nicht
Aber Tweemoji Forks
Wie sieht es aus mit Unicode
15 Support in Tweemoji
Weil ich brauche unbedingt
Das Gänse Emoji
Ohne das Gänse Emoji
Da tut sich ja gar nichts hier
Okay ich meine ich sollte mich ja nicht beschweren
Die arbeiten alle umsonst da dran
Das ist ja hier fast nichts
Fast nichts erledigt
Ja
Die Hälfte der Sachen sind
Offen hier und der Peapod ist sogar noch offen
Moment
Es gibt Tweemoji 15 gibt es mittlerweile
Wirklich
Ach es gab Tweemoji 15
Und da ist auch die Gans
Drin
Nice
Aber Moment
Das
Den Font gibt es jetzt nicht mehr
Oder
Das gibt es jetzt nicht mehr als Font
Oder gibt es das
Tweemoji 15
Moment
Den Font gibt es nicht mehr
Als Font Datei
Ja das ist ja
Massiv hängen geblieben
Und
Tweemoji
Selbst ist wahrscheinlich auch kein
Open Source mehr
Ja das ist natürlich
Kacke dann ist Tweemoji wirklich
Wirklich
Dead
Was gibt es denn für eine gute Alternative
Dead Game
Ja
Oder
Gibt es das irgendwie noch
Tweemoji
Open Source Emoji
Aber das muss doch irgendjemand mal ein Font draus bauen
Gibt es das jetzt
Oder gibt es das jetzt nicht
Tweemoji 15
Nee
Was ist das
TTF
Was
Ja
Das gibt es anscheinend nicht
Ja das ist ja richtig hängen geblieben
XTweemoji
Ja
Macht auch noch so viel Sinn
Das ein Font von X
Jetzt Tweemoji heißt
Also
Okay
Also der neue Font ist
Kein Open Source anscheinend
Ich meine ganz ehrlich
Wenn die das nicht merchen können
Soll mir
Recht sein
Dann sollen sie
Dann könnte auch irgendjemand irgendein Patcher
Script bereitstellen
Dann können die es
Zwar nicht offiziell merchen
Aber man kann es benutzen
Ja das ist dumm
Ja
TTF scheint echt deadkid zu sein
Ich warte die ganze Zeit schon auf das
Ganz Emoji
Ich möchte nicht nur Sachen administrieren
Sondern was entwickeln
Dann mach
Ich meine was soll ich dazu sagen
Es ist doch
Ist doch dein Ding
Was du machen willst also mach
Gute Frage Punkt
Moment was
Gute Frage Punkt net
Jetzt willst du mich doch veräppeln oder
Ja
Du kannst
Das kann man so pauschal nicht sagen
Du kannst ja im Informatikstudium
In jedem Bereich irgendwas machen
Musst ja erstmal angucken
Auf was du Bock hast
Das wirst du aber nach einer Weile im Studium halbwegs rauskriegen
Ob dir Programmieren eher liegt
Welche Richtung
Hardware Embedded Sachen
Wie würdest du kündigen wenn dein Chef im Urlaub ist
Ganz einfach
Bei mir ist der im Urlaub aber ich muss diese Woche kündigen
Ist egal ob dein Chef da ist oder nicht
Du schickst das einfach
Oder du wirfst das
Oder du gibst das unter Zeugen ab
Bei der Personalabteilung
Habt ihr eine Personalabteilung
Du musst
Das ist eh falsch bei deinem Chef zu kündigen
Du musst zur Personalabteilung
Dein Chef kann ja eh nichts machen
Ansonsten wichtig ist
Dass es zugestellt wird
Ob du
Was der Wim
Der Wim
Künder ist gestorben
Wirklich
Wie hieß der
Mo
Genau das hier
Ist er gestorben wirklich
Ach
Tatsächlich
Der hat Spenden für Uganda
Wie alt war der
So extrem alt
Kann er noch nicht gewesen sein
Der muss älter sein
Wenn der Ende der 80er in Amiga sich zugelegt hat
Wahrscheinlich 60
Alter
Ging im Alter von
Sowieso von uns
Wie
alt war der? 62, ah ok. An was ist er gestorben? Doppelpunkt WQ Ausrufezeichen. Also ich bin
ja eher für Shift ZZ beziehungsweise Doppelpunkt X. Ok, er war krank. Das hätte ich nicht
gedacht. Sadge. Also, wo waren wir hier stehen geblieben? Ja, gib ne Personalauftrag hin,
da hab ich es auch hingeschickt mit Rückschein etc. Du kannst es auch mit nem Zeugen abgeben.
Und schreibe in die Kündigung rein, du willst noch eine schriftliche Bestätigung. Das ist
immer ganz praktisch. Ist auch gut, wenn du den Zettel hast, aber mit Bestätigung ist
es noch besser. Aber ist es nicht gut, der Tom mit seinem Chef zu sprechen? Doch, aber
was willst du machen, wenn er gerade im Urlaub ist? Ich meine, du kannst ja schlecht sagen,
also natürlich ist es gut, aber du kannst ja schlecht sagen, ich kündige jetzt nicht
und keine Ahnung, muss dann noch ein halbes Jahr länger warten, nur weil mein Chef im
Urlaub ist. Bleibt ja nichts anderes übrig. Personalabteilung abgeben mit Zeuge und sich
das Ganze auch bestätigen lassen, dann schriftlich. Das kommt dann ein paar Tage später, aber
das ist ja nicht schlimm. Und dann kannst du ja mit deinem Chef reden, wenn der wieder
da ist. Wobei, eine Sache muss ich ja sagen, hat sich das nicht im Vorfeld schon ein bisschen
abgezeichnet, dass dein Chef nicht sogar vielleicht schon Bescheid weiß? Oder war das, wie hast
du dich denn, warum hast du dich für was Neues entschieden? War das jetzt super kurzfristig,
so innerhalb der letzten zwei Wochen, wo der im Urlaub war? Oder ist das eigentlich schon
länger mehr oder weniger so auf dem Tisch und jetzt hast du letztendlich gesagt, jetzt
reicht's? Also wenn das wirklich aus heiterem Himmel kommt, wird er wahrscheinlich recht
überrascht sein, wenn er aus dem Urlaub kommt. Aber das ist ja nicht wild. Ich meine, was
willst du machen? Bleibt ja nichts anderes übrig. Und du kannst mit dem ja im Nachhinein
auch reden. Kannst ja gleich, wenn der wieder da ist, gehst bei ihm vorbei und sagst, hier,
weiß nicht, ob du das schon gehört hast, aber ich bin in, keine Ahnung, drei Monaten
weg. Ist eine Beratung, also wenig Kontakt mit dem Chef, ja, dann wäre es mir noch mehr
egal. Ich dachte jetzt, du hast irgendwie so einen besonders persönlichen Kontakt
zu deinem Chef und ihr versteht euch gut. Ansonsten, wenn du mit deinem Chef eh nichts
groß zu tun hast, dann liegt's scheiß drauf. Ich meine, dann kannst du ja zu ihm gehen,
wenn er wieder da ist und sagst, hier, weiß nicht, ob du das mitgekriegt hast, aber bin
ich mal lange da. Und dann ist gut. Bleibt ja nichts anderes übrig. Also das kann man
schon machen, wenn du einen Zeuge dabei hast, kannst du das ohne Probleme abgeben. Ich hab
meine Kündigung auch nicht per Einschreiben hingeschickt. Ich war in der Personalabteilung
und hab noch jemand mitgenommen, der das Ganze bestätigen konnte und die haben ja auch,
die machen da kein Akt, musst du dir keine Gedanken machen. Also, wenn du das da mit
Zeuge abgibst und du schreibst dir am besten in die Kündigung auch rein, dass du hier
um schriftliche, du bittest hier um, du möchtest eine schriftliche Bestätigung und dann schicken
die da auch eine schriftliche Bestätigung. Das klappt, also das klappt bei den meisten,
wenn sonst nichts klappt, aber das klappt bei den meisten. Ja, denke ich auch. Du kannst
die Eingabe der Benutzerdaten auch mit SkeletonUI machen. Ja, also, ich meine, benutzen wir
doch schon. Achso, du meinst hier drin in der Form. Ne, wir machen, das werde ich so
wahrscheinlich nicht machen. Ich glaube, ich lasse auf eine eigene Seite redirecten
und mache das dann da drin. Mal überlegen, mal überlegen. So, ich muss mal kurz die Musik
an. Das nervt mich gerade ein bisschen, das ist das 500. Mal jetzt. Wir machen ein bisschen
Wupp, Wupp, Wupp an. Okay, komm her. Wupp, Wupp, Wupp. Wupp, Wupp, Wupp, Wupp, Wupp, Wupp,
Wupp. Ausgewuppt. Wupp, Wupp, Wupp, Wupp, Wupp. Wie viele Tabs? Oh ja, sind ein paar Tabs
und hier habe ich noch ein paar. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo es mehr sind. Da oder da? Irgendwo
muss ich ja mit meinem RAM hin. Für mich war es länger auf dem Tisch, ob er es gecheckt
hat. Achso, da habe ich gerade schon was zu gesagt, ja. So, also, Chat-Gear, weiter geht's.
High-Performer-Crime-Set-Mindset heute wieder. Package-Updates, immer noch keine neuen Sachen
dazugekommen, weil ich Use the Arch, by the way. Wo sind wir? Oh, guck mal, es ist kaputt.
Es ist, es ist broken. Wir haben es, Leute, wir haben, kann es sein, dass wir es kaputt
hinterlassen haben. NPM, Run-Dev. Wupp, Wupp, Wupp, Wupp, Wupp. Okay, wir haben es kaputt
hinterlassen, das ist immer ziemlich kacke. Ach nee, das liegt daran, weil die Sachen
nicht importiert sind und so. Ja, das brauchen wir doch eh nicht. Ah, nice, alles klar. Perfekt.
Excellent, excellent. Okay, also, folgende Sachen habe ich heute vor-, ach, das habe
ich ja blöd. Guck mal, das kann man da oben gar nicht anklicken. Das ist ja dumm, das
muss-, das muss ich auch noch fixen. Ja, da klickt man so ganz instinktiv drauf, um wieder
auf die Startseite zu kommen, ne? Das-, das muss schon ordentlich gemacht werden. Gehen
wir mal in die Layouts-Datei. Gucken wir mal, wo das hier definiert ist, 4-Chapter-Text,
okay. Machen wir da einfach mal einen Link drumherum. Ja, wir machen einen Link drumherum
und auf die Startseite. Nice, Funst, okay. Und das-, das-, das ist auch noch nicht gelinkt?
Dann brauchen wir jetzt noch einen Button unserer Startseite. Ne, in den Layouts brauchen
wir einen Button. Ne, wo hab ich-, wo hab-, wo hab ich diesen Button? Layouts, oder? Hier,
hier ist der Button, okay. Äh, Button. Ja, gibt auch keinen Button, sondern gibt einen
Link und das geht auf Create. Ja, nice. Kann ich hier navigaten. Perfekt. Moin Max, erste
Woche der Fachinformatiker-Anwendungsentwicklung-Ausbildung vorbei, macht richtig Bock. Wir machen aber
leider hauptsächlich PHP. Chatge, Prage für Nudelwasser. Alle eine Runde Prage, damit
man das übersteht. Aber eins-, einen Vorteil hast du, du kannst damit übelst Kohle machen.
Du kannst damit übel-, später kannst du, wenn du dich damit auskennst, kannst du übelst
Kohle machen. Hab ich PHP gesagt? Äh, SAP. Ich-, ich meinte auch SAP. Wenn ich PHP gesagt
hab, dann bin ich-, bin ich verwirrt, ja. Aber du brauchst-, du brauchst für SAP besor-,
noch-, nochmal, also wirklich Prage, weil da hätt ich wirklich keinen Bock drauf. Du
willst Fullstack machen. Weiß ich nicht, ob man mit SAP Fullstack machen kann. Doch,
du kannst bestimmt SAP im Frontend und SAP im Backend machen, ob man das haben will.
Wie viel verbraucht der Chrome an RAM? Tatsächlich gar nicht so viel, weil Chrome ziemlich high
IQ ist. Guck mal, kaum was verbraucht. Weil Chrome ziemlich high IQ ist und ja, guck
mal, ich hab eine fette VM noch laufen, ich hab nur 26 GB RAM in use. Und das ist noch
alles optimistisch belegt, eben voraus gecached und so. Also insofern. Die meisten Tabs machen
Badge, ja, tatsächlich. Aber irgendwie muss ich mit dem RAM ja hin. Wie man am Anfang
mit SAP arbeiten kann, ist doch ganz einfach. Wenn man in einem Ausbildungsbetrieb ist,
der hauptsächlich SAP macht, macht man in der Ausbildung natürlich auch SAP. Es ist
ja nicht so, als könnte man sich das groß aussuchen. Wenn du in irgendeinem Team oder
in einer Abteilung oder vielleicht sogar in einem ganzen Betrieb SAP machen, kannst
du nicht sagen, ey, ich mach jetzt keinen SAP. Ich bin zwar Azubi bei euch, aber interessiert
mich nicht, ich mach keinen SAP. Ich meine, kannst du schon machen. Ob du dann eine gute
Ausbildung hast, ist halt wieder was anderes. ABAP ist ganz großer Painschamp, ja. Wie
schaut denn das eigentlich aus? Muss mir da immer wieder mal irgendwelche Beispiele angucken,
weil ich das immer verdränge. Den Grundzügenähnlichkeiten zu Koboll aufweist. Oh ja, das klingt ja richtig
gut. Boah, mein Auge. Ich seh nichts mehr. ABAP. Haben die ein Beispiel? Okay, das sieht
wirklich räudig aus, Alter. Warum ist das eigentlich ABAP? Warum haben die das nicht
mal durch irgendwas halbwegs modernes ersetzt? Wahrscheinlich weil sie damit Schulungen und
viel Geld verdienen. Oder es ist einfach zu tief integriert in allem. Wobei, du müsstest
das ja nicht austauschen. Du könntest ja was Neues parallel anbieten. Das sieht wirklich
wie eine richtige Scheißsprache aus. Gäbe ich euch recht, Chat? ABAP-Example. Was haben
wir da sonst noch Schönes? ABAP-Examples. Moment, Multiline Comments macht man mit einem
Und? Das ist so eine Mischung. Wisst ihr, wie das aussieht? Das sieht aus wie eine Mischung
aus, also Chainlaw ist ja der Meinung, es hat nichts mit Visual Basic und Basic zu tun,
aber ich finde, ein bisschen schon. Das ist so eine Mischung aus SQL und Basic. So sieht
das aus. Glücklicherweise brauchst du nicht, wie bei Koboll, irgendwelche Zeilennummern
vorne. Endif und so, das ist eindeutig so ein bisschen Visual Basic. Das ist so eine
Mischung aus SQL und Basic. Like und sowas klingt eher nach SQL. Und die stehen, glaube
ich, auf alles groß geschrieben. Aber trotzdem, ich meine, hey, wenn die einem da das Geld
für in Popo schieben, dann kann man sicherlich auch Koboll, äh, nicht Koboll, ABAP programmieren.
Spielen Tabs und Spaces eine Rolle? Ich gehe mal nicht davon aus. Das ist einfach nur gut
eingerückt, oder? Oder müssen hier Spaces sein? Nee, wahrscheinlich nicht. Das ist bestimmt
einfach nur zur besseren Lesbarkeit eingerückt. Gibt es, gibt es, Moment, jetzt müssen wir
mal gucken. VS Code, ABAP. Gibt es da eine Extension? Ah, doch, da war was, da war was.
ABAP. Oh, ist ja sehr beliebt, wie es aussieht. Ob es dafür gescheites Autocomplete gibt?
Eigentlich sind solche Sprachen recht easy Auto zu completen, wenn sich jemand die Mühe
gemacht hat. Übrigens, jetzt wo ich gerade den Forums Eintrag sehe, Garmin hat das hinbekommen,
meine Fitness Uhr updatet wieder. Hier, da war ja das Geflämme, das Geflämme war ja groß,
aber sie haben es tatsächlich geschafft. Ich kann, ups, ich kann meine Fitness Uhr wieder
updaten. Ja, dann, wenn du, wenn du nicht auf ABAP stehst, kannst du ja vielleicht in
deiner Ausbildung auch noch mal bei anderen Teams reingucken. Kegweight Business, das finde
ich gut. Es wird hinzugefügt. Kegweight Business, das ist nice, das gefällt mir. Der
Chainlaw ist immer auf dem aktuellen Stand, was das Emote-Game angeht. Morgen wieder fett
Kegweight Business. Ne, ich nicht. Morgen, morgen ist noch Freige. Ne, das nicht. Wir
müssen nicht jedes, nicht jedes Keg-Emote reinmachen. Wir haben ja schon doch recht
viele Keg-Emotes. Das ist auch nicht schlecht hier. Keg, Keg-Browse. Ich glaube, das wurde
gelöscht. Das ist normal, so die ersten 40 Minuten passiert meistens nicht viel. Ich denke mal,
die meisten von euch müssen morgen Keg-Business machen, oder? Oder gibt es noch irgendwelche
Montags-Frei-Enjoyer hier im Chat? Jemand morgen frei und nicht Urlaub haben? Wobei,
Urlaub auch. Irgendjemand morgen nicht Business stellt? Morgen Karriere grind. Erster Tag nach
Urlaub, oh ne. Das suckt. Das ist immer richtig kacke, bis man da wieder reingekommen ist. Du
würdest eher den Freitag bei einer für Tagewoche nehmen. Warum das denn? Freitag ist doch super
entspannter Tag. Warum willst du Freitag nehmen? Montag ist taktisch deutlich geschickter. Montag
sind die Leute alle super motiviert und viele nervige Sachen passieren montags. Viele nervige
Sachen passieren montags. Deswegen ist es sehr sinnvoll, Montags frei zu nehmen und Freitag eher
noch eine Runde abzuchillen mit den anderen Leuten, weil die am Freitag auch alle keinen
Bock mehr haben, was zu machen. Nein, wir haben jetzt genug Emails, Chat. Das reicht für heute.
Quick Maths. Genug Emails. Dienstag bis Freitag ist das Beste. Das sehe ich auch so. Der wilde
Igel blickt durch. So sieht es aus. So, wo sind wir stehen geblieben? Da. Also, Ziel ist folgendes.
Ich sage das jetzt mal für heute. Ziel ist folgendes. Ich möchte, wenn ich hier auf Add-In
klicke, ein Formular bekommen, wo ich meinen Account eintragen kann. Ich will so eine Art
Assistent haben. Da habe ich nämlich gesehen, dass Skeleton UI tatsächlich so was eingebaut hat.
Nennt sich dort Steppers. Da kann man sowas hier machen, guckt. Kann man so einen Assistent bauen.
Was ganz praktisch ist für mich, weil ich brauche ja eh zwei Steps. Ich brauche Username,
Passwort, Eingabe. Eingabe vom Hersteller. Dann muss ich gucken, ob das Login geht. Und erst,
wenn das Login geht, dann will ich den nächsten Step haben. Nächster Step ist dann sowas wie
Eingabe vom Abfrageintervall und sowas. Also wir brauchen quasi so einen Zwei-Step-Wizard.
Wup, wup, wup, wup, wup. Was machen wir, zeige ich dir. Das zeige ich dir. Und zwar,
wir bauen ein Web-Interface für dieses Home-Assistant-Add-On hier. Wobei es kein
Home-Assistant-Add-On ist. Das kann man ja auch Stand-Alone verwenden. Das habe ich gebaut. Da
kann man für Fiat, für Jeep, für Ram, für Dodge und für Alfa-Romeo-Elektroautos Informationen
von einer nicht so ganz offiziellen API abfragen. Also wir fragen das schon von der offiziellen
API ab, aber die ist nicht dafür gedacht, dass man sie benutzt. So, und nachdem ich immer mehr
Leute danach gefragt habe, ob man das nicht auch gescheit Stand-Alone benutzen könnte,
also sprich die Daten an irgendeinen MQTT-Server schicken nicht zwangsläufig für Home-Assistant,
und nachdem das Home-Assistant-interne-Konfigurations-Overview-Ding ein
bisschen zu minimalistisch ist, zum Beispiel um mehrere Accounts zu werden, mache ich ein
eigenes Web-Interface dafür, wo man das konfigurieren kann. Ist Ram nicht Dodge?
Anscheinend nicht. Guck, Connect-Ram-Trucks, Connect-Dodge sind unterschiedliche Dinger.
Ich weiß nicht warum, aber anscheinend sind das nicht die gleichen. Richtig.
Nach wie vielen Jahren bist du eigentlich auf die 4-Tage-Woche umgestiegen und hat
dein Arbeitgeber das sofort akzeptiert und sich erst quergestellt? Dazu habe ich schon
ein paar Videos gemacht, da musst du mal auf YouTube gucken, wenn du es ganz ausführlich
wissen willst. Es ist letztlich auch gar nicht so lange her, also ich habe über meine Teilzeit-Journey
schon ein bisschen was erzählt, also aber um es kurz zu machen, wie lange hast du vorher gearbeitet?
Ich würde sagen fünf oder sechs Jahre habe ich gearbeitet, also ich zähle mal Ausbildung mit,
ich zähle mal die Ausbildung mit und ja, also ich habe das nicht sofort, das wurde nicht sofort
akzeptiert und mein damaliger Arbeitgeber hat gesagt, gibt es nicht, wollen wir nicht und dann
musste ich damals zum Betriebsrat und dann ging es. Aber da musst du mal auf YouTube gucken, da
habe ich eins, zwei richtig ausführliche Videos zugemacht, ja. Mal kurz gucken hier, Teilzeit,
da habe ich das, also ich habe es bestimmt da in Kurzform erzählt und da etwas länger erzählt.
Hier ist der Max, Karriere hemmend oder wie auch immer angesehen wurde, nicht ganz so viel weniger,
also wenn jetzt meinem Chef damals, das war jemand, der hat so eine gewisse Erziehungsabsicht noch
gehabt. Ja, hier erzähle ich das, das kannst du dir in Ruhe angucken, dann weißt du Bescheid danach.
Chandler, was ist mit dir heute schon wieder los? Rein in die vier Tage Woche,
beste. Egregal, kann ich dazu nur sagen. Wie bist du dazu gekommen? Warum hast du dich dafür
entschieden? Gut, dann würde ich sagen, wir fangen jetzt mal an, High Performer Mindset,
42 Minuten bis es richtig losgeht. Okay, let's go, wir bauen eine Form. So, ja,
wie fangen wir denn am besten an? Wie baut man denn jetzt hier eine schöne Form? Ist jetzt nicht
so, als bin ich der tolle CSS-Kenner. Also, so, Card brauchen wir schon mal nicht. Backend
ersetzen, warum soll ich das Backend ersetzen? So, ich kopiere mir jetzt erstmal dieses Beispiel
hier, der Stepper. Card full, ja, lassen wir das mal da, würde ich sagen. Card, ja, das können
wir so lassen. Das schmeißen wir weg und pasten jetzt. Oh, jetzt ist es kaputt. Warum? Ah, weil
es nicht importiert wird. Warum? Wer kennt sich mit dem Svelte-Add-on aus? Warum gibt es jetzt
hier keine Möglichkeit zu sagen, Import? Normalerweise in Visual Studio drücke ich jetzt
oder in Rider drücke ich jetzt Alt-Enter und dann kriege ich sowas zum importieren. Was witzig ist,
weil wenn ich jetzt einfach so sage, Stepper, dann fügt das ein, aber nicht, wenn schon drinne
copy-pasted ist. Also, was auch immer da kaputt ist. Ruby, hast du das Daily Scrum verpasst? Ist
heute ausgefallen. Firma hat das neu eingeführt, ich mache derzeit mein Informatik-Fernstudium und
deswegen... Ach so, ah, okay, du hast tatsächlich noch richtig Ambitionen hier, sehe ich schon. Ich
kann doch eigentlich durch die Stunden reduzieren und nebenbei noch einen anderen Job machen oder
sprich vom Gesetzgeber was dagegen? Nö. Kannst du machen. Es kommt ein bisschen drauf an, wenn du
quasi direkte Konkurrenz oder so machst für deinen Arbeitgeber und so, da gibt es sicherlich Probleme,
aber sagen wir mal, wenn du bei einer Versicherung arbeitest und privat streamst auf Twitch und
YouTube-Videos machst, das beißt sich ja überhaupt nicht. Gaming, YouTube-Videos und sowas. Ey,
du musst nicht sagen, wo du arbeitest. Du musst sagen, dass du einen Nebenjob hast quasi und das
musst du anmelden. Aber die können da auch gar nichts dagegen sagen in dem Sinne. Die können
es eigentlich einfach nur abnicken. Es sei denn, es gibt wirklich eines dieser wenigen Gründe,
diese wenigen Gründe, warum sie was dagegen sagen können. Die können labern, so viel wie sie wollen.
Da gibt es ja relativ enge rechtliche Rahmen, was du machen darfst und was nicht. Nur weil
denen da irgendwas vorschwebt, heißt ja noch lange nicht, dass sie das dann auch wirklich versuchen
irgendwie durchzusetzen. Okay, also wir bauen jetzt. Okay, ich glaube, wir müssen mal die
Breite etwas beschränken. Machen wir mal hier. Breite darf 6,90 sein. Okay, perfekt. Next,
next, complete. Okay, sehr schön. Also wir bauen jetzt eine Form. Das heißt Header. Ich
gebe dir Header, Alter. So, das heißt sowas wie Add Account. Oh, sieht schon mal gut aus. Fertig,
completed, finished. Die sollen sich mal nicht zu sehr anstellen, weil vielleicht ist er sonst
nicht mal lange da, wenn sie ihm auf den Sack gehen. OBS Chat Overlay hat kein 7TV. Was ist
das? Warum? Doch, das hat bestimmt 7TV, aber ich vermute mal, dass das nicht... Probiert nochmal.
Ne? Wie, kein Keg Browse? Was ist das denn? Das ist ja Keg Wait, Alter. Da muss ich mal gucken,
dass ich ein anderes Chat Overlay verwende. Das ist ja nix. Ich meine, Leute, können wir nicht
einfach selbst ein Chat Overlay machen? Was ist denn, wenn ich diesen Chat hier nehme? Moment,
das testen wir jetzt mal kurz. So, Achtung hier, Add. Window Capture, nicht YouTube. Twitch Chat,
jawoll. Aber ich glaube, das skaliert nicht richtig, oder? Das sieht dann einfach kacke
aus, wenn es so klein ist. Ja, das sieht scheiße aus. Naja, so schlecht sieht es gar nicht aus,
aber die Uhrzeit müsste weg, ja? Wir testen das mal kurz. Ich mache den Chat weg und das
Ganze kommt natürlich... Aber der Zeilenumbruch stimmt jetzt nicht, guckt mal. Daran liegt das.
Okay, das ist natürlich doof. Da muss ich mal gucken, wie wir das auf die Reihe kriegen. Ich
meine, ich könnte auch einfach das Fenster resizen, irgendwie so, aber so, dass die normalen Sachen
da drauf passen. So, Window Capture. Ich bin verwirrt. Window Capture? Ah, die Anzeige,
ich blicke nicht mehr durch. Wo ist der Chat? Hier, ne, das ist der Chat. Window Capt...